hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta emisión vamos a
abordar el tema de las infancias y
adolescencias transgénero y es por eso
que nos acompaña tania morales ella es
abogada defensora de derechos humanos de
las infancias y adolescencias trans hace
años se convirtió en una enorme
referente y activista y además es la
fundadora de la asociación por las
infancias transgénero de hecho fue la
impulsora de la ley de infancias trans
en la ciudad de mexico tania morales
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de france 24 muchas
gracias por la invitación y gracias a
ustedes tania bueno su lucha nació de la
mano de su hijo louis acompañándolo a
diferencia de tantas familias no en las
que a diferencia de lo que sucedió en su
caso se marginan a quienes a quienes son
diferentes entre comillas no usted sin
embargo acompañado todo el proceso de su
hijo de louis cómo fue ese primer
acercamiento a lo que imagino sería un
universo totalmente desconocido para
usted no al comienzo
así es
no sabíamos nada acerca del tema de
familia no teníamos ningún referente de
una persona trans y pues sí fue un reto
el hecho de comenzar en espigar ya saber
de qué estaba hablando a los 13 años fue
que habló con la familia y nos explicó
que era un hombre y mujer como la vemos
aquí
en el momento del nacimiento y pues en
méxico no teníamos mayores referentes y
organizaciones entonces somos que hacer
una investigación de éste
de todo lo que se pudiera en la
literatura en otras organizaciones en
otros países
sucedió también cuando louis tenía 13
años no me imagino cómo recibió ese
momento cómo fue ese momento cuando
llegaron esas palabras no y el proceso
por el que habrá atravesado el todo ese
tiempo
fue difícil porque no la verdad es que
no sabíamos acerca del lote no se estaba
hablando sin embargo a través del tiempo
nos damos cuenta que con sus palabras en
las posibilidades que tenía del lenguaje
durante su vida en diferentes momentos
de su vida nos transmitió valoración el
día de hoy a los tres años a los siete
años de diferentes formas nos decía era
un nombre sin embargo tampoco por la
educación que teníamos en la familia
conocimiento no sabíamos que realmente
no estaba hablando de su identidad de
género
y fue hasta los 13 años en un libro que
yo le regalé encontró cuál era la
defunción del día de género y comenzó a
nombrarse como un hombre atrás
o sea él mismo la encontró en un libro y
se lo transmitió a ustedes a la familia
maravilloso y cómo fue ese proceso de
transición de louis o cómo es
pues mira la verdad en el ambiente
familiar en una situación bastante
sencilla lo que sabíamos es que si ella
estaba planteando esta esta forma de
vida de la que escucharle y había que
respetar que yo soy abogada
y pues sabemos que lo importante es
generar un espacio digamos de aceptación
en su entorno entonces fuimos de la mano
de la familia comunicando a nuestros
entornos círculos familiares también
fuimos a su colegio a solicitar que se
les respetara con su nombre con su
género y que pudiera practicar y miradas
cuando se trata de diferenciación de
género con el primero masculino y
después nos encontramos con la
complicación legislativa o la complica
la complicación de acceder a una un acta
de nacimiento que es en méxico es el
documento de identidad de todas las
personas
el acceso a más derechos entonces fueron
una serie de etapas que tuvimos que
enfrentar como familia y después
pensamos que no sólo se podía quedar en
la cuestión familiar sino que todas las
personas trans que son muchas
requerían de un camino allanado para
poder acceder a todos sus derechos a
hacer hacer respetar los dos y tenía
para allanar ese camino bueno
precisamente usted fundó la asociación
por las infancias transgénero desde esta
asociación ustedes ayudan a familiares
no de personas que están viviendo esta
situación y me imagino que cada caso
debe tener por supuesto sus
particularidades no tenía con qué
inquietudes con qué reacciones suele
encontrarse usted
pues bueno tenemos familiares que no
saben nada así como nosotros y quieren
aprender tener los hemos encontrado
también de un gran porcentaje de mujeres
de madres que son quienes quieren
acompañar a sus hijas y que tienen la
oposición del padre eso es algo también
como bastante común el 85 por ciento de
las veces únicamente la madre es quien
acompaña el proceso de recurso y
potencia de género y tenemos un sinfín
de complicaciones aprender a nosotros
como familia es cannes porque en méxico
todavía no tenemos un protocolo
educativo obligatorio que
que te obligue a que las escuelas
respete el nombre y género de las niños
trans a pesar de que no tengas cuenten
con su acta de nacimiento entonces pues
eso genera todos los escolares de
exclusión también tenemos buenas buenas
respuestas eso sí pero depende de cada
escuela depende de cada comunidad de
educación tenemos tenemos verdad pues a
las familias les compete el reeducar a
los entornos educativos a la comunidad
escolar a las mismas escuelas y hablando
tan ya de entornos que son de alguna
manera por llamarlo de alguna manera
quizás hostiles no vivimos en un mundo
por supuesto que todavía es
absolutamente heterosis normativo y en
el que el binarismo en términos de
género no de hombre o mujer continúa
haciendo esas etiquetas no que nos
conozcan cuando nacemos etiquetas que
representan obstáculos para muchísimas
personas para las infancias trans para
todas las disidencias no a nivel de
género estas disidencias que vienen de
algún modo como a sacudir esas
estructuras no tenía aquí pudimos
aprender de las infancias y del asado
en trans
pues es maravilloso porque a quienes
estamos cerca de las infancias y
adolescencias trans nos permite
cuestionar más todos estos aprendizajes
en todo el género entonces por ejemplo
podemos ver que la educación basada en
género en el sexo y en la diferenciación
o alejamiento de los géneros y los sexos
no sesiona de negar a todas las personas
a las personas que escriben hoy a las
personas trans también limitadas formas
de expresión y las formas de crecimiento
a todas las personas limita la libertad
de las cosas entonces conforme hemos las
familias que vivimos en el día de
acompañando a personas trans pues
podemos ayudar a cuestionar también en
nuestros entornos todo lo que es
referente al género y todas estas
imposiciones de género creo que hay una
gran posibilidad de aperturarse y de y
de conocer los derechos de las personas
no todas las personas trans
tenemos derecho a la educación a una
vida libre de violencia a la salud sin
discriminación y al gozar del espacio
público etcétera
álava están ya de discriminaciones de
tipos de violencia de situaciones buenos
de obstáculos no que deben enfrentar las
personas trans en este sentido cuáles
son los principales obstáculos que
existen para reconocer los derechos de
las personas trans con se trata de
menores de edad la educación es una
cuestión clave de verdad la educación
por supuesto pero que básicamente lo más
importante
es lo principal el inicio del camino es
el derecho a tener un documento de
identidad el nombre de género conocido
es el primer obstáculo porque a partir
de méxico te decía el acta de nacimiento
pero un dni en otros países
hoy mismo en españa se está dando esta
esta discusión acerca de cómo obtener un
documento de identidad que te permite
tener acceso a los a los derechos
económicos políticos sociales y
culturales digamos es un derecho
principal entonces cuando no tienes un
documento de identidad refleja como de
género pues difícilmente puedes acceder
a la educación a la salud
a los demás derechos en méxico
específicamente tenemos una un avance
muy importante que me parece que es a
nivel mundial es en un estado de la
república en el estado de jalisco y
permitió a través de un decreto basado
en el sistema interamericano de derechos
humanos que cualquier persona trans o
cualquier persona que quiera modificar
en su documento de identidad el nombre y
el género por tener una identidad de
género distinta puede hacerlo esto
incluye a niñas niños y adolescentes y
no requiere de patologización lo
requiere de dictámenes médicos es un
solo trámite administrativo en donde a
quien se escuchas a la persona es decir
nosotros nosotros acompañamos a familias
que tenían niñas de 5 o 6 años que
pudieron hacer este cambio en su acta de
nacimiento
algo muy importante también es que se
consideró la perspectiva de género y
fuimos escuchados como sociedad civil
entonces está esta obtención del acta de
nacimiento no requiere de solicitud de
madre y pareja o sea puede venir la cual
dos personas pueden ir puede ir una sola
de las personas y actualmente está
viéndose una vía para que una
y una institución del gobierno que
quiera acompañar a personas trans
menores de 18 años que no cuenten con el
acompañamiento y el apoyo de linux
absolutamente de tania y por supuesto
también lamentablemente en un lado ven a
una contracara a esta empatía con la que
se manifiesta usted que se ve en medios
de comunicación es redes sociales
discursos muchas veces cargados incluso
de cierto odio que dicen que a veces son
muy pequeños pequeñas para tomar este
tipo de decisiones que le respondería a
estas personas usted pues eso es una
pregunta que me hacen comúnmente yo lo
que este fondo es acuerda usted se dio
cuenta que tenía engendros que tiene eso
no hay diferencia entre personas trans y
personas y todas las personas tenemos ya
de género y damos cuenta de esta
identidad de género en nuestros primeros
años de vida y es discriminatorio
se le pida solo a las personas que
esperen hasta tener 18 años para poder
ser reconocidas frente al estado y otra
cuestión es el estado no pueden
discriminar las personas pueden
discriminar y eso no está bien pero el
estado en las instituciones del estado
no puede discriminar a las personas esas
respuestas tenía morales muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en france 24
por favor a usted ya nuestra audiencia
le invitamos a continuar informándose en
el resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com
[Música]